the romantic story of love tells us that
our search for a partner is inspired
above all else by a desire to find
someone who can make us happy but the
truth is a little more confused and
peculiar for one of the oddest aspects
of love is that in tracking down a mate
we don't in fact look out for just
anyone who seems kind good and
attractive we look out for someone who
will fulfill a number of pre-existing
psychological requirements which could
include a subterranean appetite for
frustration and humiliation we are
constrained in our love choices by what
we learnt of love as children adult love
he is in central ways a search for a
rediscovery of emotions first known in
childhood in order to prove exciting and
attractive the partner we pick must
refocus we once had around parental
figures and these feelings though they
may include tenderness and satisfaction
are also likely to feature the more
troubling range of emotions
perhaps the desire to prove ourselves to
someone who was always slightly
skeptical of us or the feeling of shame
around sexuality or a need to cheer up
someone with depressive tendencies we
can find ourselves rejecting certain
candidates in adulthood not so much
because they are wrong as because they
feel a little bit too right that is we
dim lis ensured that they're not going
to make us suffer in the ways we need to
suffer in order to feel that love is
real
the romantic view of love suggests that
we end up in bad relationships by
mistake
the psychological view suggests that we
end up in tricky places by unconscious
intent without being fully aware of our
wish we need our partner to have a
failing that a parents once had so that
we can repeat flawed but potent dynamic
we once experienced as children though
in most cases were drawn to people with
the very same failings as a parent
occasionally a relationship pays tribute
to a parent's failings in a slightly
different way we act towards our partner
as our parent once acted towards us we
push the partner into the role we once
inhabited as a child we may leave our
partner uncertain of where they stand or
deeply aware of their inadequacies we
may shout at their failures or complain
of their inadequate performance in the
eyes of the world it seems we are fated
either to seek out the fault of a parent
in a partner or to mimic the fault of
the parent with a partner
either way the fault of the parent
remains central to our love choices
without it we may simply not be able to
feel passionate or tender with someone
we might imagine we would only be
attracted to admirable traits to
perfection to very positive things about
another yet just below the conscious
radar it is the failings that your ass
in because we don't automatically see
what we're doing
it can be helpful actively to try to
compare past and present for example to
reflect on how a parent needs feel and
then to audit how we often feel around a
partner the correspondences can be as
striking as they are humbling we become
aware of the tricky scripts with
following to want to leave a
relationship at once but this implies
that we might easily be able to overcome
sort of people we're attracted to a less
dramatic but still hopeful strategy is
to try to deal more successfully with
our compulsions within an existing
relationship
what this involves is accepting the
extent to which we're liable to be
dealing with the issues in our couple
with some of the immaturity of a child
the child we were when we first
encounter the compelling flaws of our
parents we should feel sympathy for
ourselves for facing a double challenge
in love were attracted to adults who
have some of the failings we knew in
childhood but then in dealing with these
failings we have none of the resources
wisdom and competence that someone who'd
enjoyed adequate parenting in relation
to them would have been able to master
the failings were most attracted to
become those Willie's set up to deal
with we love a slightly distant person
but we can't deal with the silences
we're drawn to free spirits but we can't
deal with the attendant anxieties in
other words our emotional legacy doesn't
just involve an attraction to certain
failings it also involved a style of
responding to these failings that stuck
at the level of traumatized childhood
and typically involves panic terror cold
withdrawal or projection shame and
obsessive rigidity we should undertake
an unusual thought experiment to imagine
the responses that an ideal mature
person might display in relation to the
challenges we face we should imagine
what the mature person might do in
relation to a partner who was often
working or who made them feel ashamed of
sex or whose career was in decline a
mature person wouldn't be pleased or
unfazed but they would have the inner
skills to navigate the rocks calmly they
would resist jealous rages or silent
sulks they would know how to wait for
the right moment deliver a point they
might have the inner freedom to make a
joke out of a problem they wouldn't have
to crush a weaker party keeping such
possibilities in our minds helps us to
see that our own instinctive responses
aren't necessary or normal they are the
responses of people who underwent a lot
of trouble before they had any idea of
how to cope with it we should create a
zone of possibility in which we can
regularly imagine having a different and
more constructive response to our
partners oddities we should accept that
the way to have a better relationship is
likely to lie
in firing the partner we are with them
for tricky but firm reasons but in doing
some internal work to learn better how
to cope with the problems we face with
them we can come to accept that being
uncomplicated ly happy in love was never
going to be our leading psychological
possibility in our childhoods but that
we may gradually learn to make our peace
character traits in our partners that
are as troublesome as they are
you
you